Відома українська волонтерка Юлія Паєвська, відома як Тайра, 8 років рятувала життя військових і мирних мешканців на Донбасі.
Від початку повномасштабної війни Юлія перебувала в Маріуполі,
а 16 березня разом з водієм потрапила в полон росіян.
Мені все одно, на кого її обміняють, я дію як приватна особа, як член родини,
і я за те, щоб її обміняли на кого завгодно і якомога швидше.
Вадим Пузанов - чоловік Тайри.
Відколи дружина потрапила в полон, не може займатися нічим іншим,
як домагатися її звільнення з російського полону.
Однак попри широкий медійний розголос за два місяці справа так і не просунулася.
Росіяни відмовляються надавати українській стороні будь-яку інформацію про волонтерку.
Мені навіть невідомий її статус, тобто ніхто не повідомляє, що саме їй закидають, в якому статусі вона перебуває.
Чи це є якесь карне провадження, чи це стан військовополоненого, і тоді її можна буде обміняти.
Жодної інформації російська сторона не надає.
Тому незрозуміло, яким чином можна працювати, вплинути на ситуацію.
Попри те, що Росія намагається заперечувати утримання Тайри в полоні,
через кілька днів після викрадення жінку показали в кайданках і з загримованими синцями на обличчі
на російському пропагандистському каналі НТВ та на телеканалах так званого "ДНР".
У фільмі її називають нацисткою і послідовницею Гітлера.
Рідні і колеги Тайри стверджують, що звинувачення абсурдні.
Не можу сказати, що вона якийсь радикал чи нацист чи ще щось.
Вона, як сказати, як справжній медик, який аполітичний і надає допомогу всім, хто її потребує.
Юлія працювала парамедиком на фронті ще з 2014 року.
Надавала екстрену медичну допомогу, а також евакуювала з гарячих точок як поранених військових, так і цивільних.
Організувала свій такий підрозділ "Ангели Тайри", який вже зараз знають в усій Україні.
Рятувала на полі бою і наших поранених, до речі, надавала допомогу і російським пораненим,
як це, власне, передбачено всіма конвенціями.
Рятувала дітей з-під обстрілів. Вона вивезла, дуже багато її підрозділ вивіз дітей.
За день до полону, Тайра передала команді інформагенції Associated Press картку на 256 ГБ зі своєї нагрудної камери.
Зйомка документувала будні парамедиків в Маріуполі з першого дня війни.
Журналісти заховали флешку у тампон - тільки так їм вдалося провезти картку через 15 російських блокпостів.
Щоразу, коли українська сторона подає Тайру в списках на обмін, росіяни викреслюють її з цих списків.
Причин ніхто не пояснює. Через те, що російська пропаганда створила їй образ нацистки,
низка міжнародних посередників і ЗМІ відмовляються повідомляти про долю волонтерки.
Особливо з французькими було дуже важко.
Щойно я починав перемовини з не буду називати якими виданнями, але щойно мова заходила про "Азов" і нібито звʼязок Юлії з "Азовом" -
вони відмовилися одразу співпрацювати, вони втрачали всякий інтерес і казали, що ні.
Я розповідав їм, що "Азов" є частиною Збройних сил, що це Національна гвардія України.
І що цей весь пропагандистский російский наратив недоречний в цьому питанні.
Завдяки відео з нагрудної камери, поширеному Associated Press,
про справу Тайри знову активно заговорили у ЗМІ та соцмережах.
Утім, жодної нової інформації щодо статусу Тайри в полоні так і немає.
Тому Вадим намагається сам вичислити можливе місце перебування своєї дружини,
моніторячи російські джерела інформації та у так званих "ДНР/ЛНР".
У якихось пабліках з тієї сторони я знайшов інформацію, що один з активістів у Херсоні був затриманий,
і у нього було знайдене фото з Тайрою.
В тій публікації було сказано, що його доправлять до Донецького СІЗО, де його вже чекає Тайра.
Тобто це такі непрямі свідоцтва того, де вона може перебувати.
Відколи Тайра зникла в середині березня, Вадиму жодного разу не вдалося напряму зв'язатися з дружиною.
Єдине, так би мовити, "вітання" від Юлії він отримав, власне, з пропагандистського фільму НТВ.
У мене немає жодного з нею зв'язку, тільки в цьому пропагандистському НТВ-шному фільмі, не знаю,
чому вони таки включили такий епізод, де вона передала, так би мовити, мені вітання персональне.
Якщо додивитися до кінця, там є згадування про мене, ну.. Не знаю, чому НТВ… такий момент… контакту..
Близькі Тайри вважають, що розголос в українських та міжнародних ЗМІ може допомогти не тільки Юлії,
але й іншим заточеним українкам вибратися з російського полону.
У росіян, які вбивають наше мирне населення, немає ніяких принципів.
І коли вони розстрілюють цивільних людей, жінок та дітей, той же пологовий будинок в Маріуполі,
тобто вони не мають ніяких цінностей, ніяких принципів узагалі.
І тут мова не про порятунок однієї конкретної жінки.
Можливо, Тайра буде уособлювати собою тих медиків і жінок, які пішли на фронт.
Оскільки дипломатичні канали не працюють, Вадим вважає, що доля Тайри буде вирішуватися на полі бою.
Коли Україна розпочне успішну контратаку, краще запрацюють і дипломатичні канали.
На думку чоловіка, Тайра нині потрібна росіянам насамперед для пропагандистських цілей.
Через неї вони хочуть демонізувати і дегуманізувати все, що ми українці вважаємо героїчним.
Все, що ми вважаємо доблесним.
Тобто через Юлю вони намагаються показати: дивіться, те, що ваші герої, яких ви вважаєте героями,
насправді монстри, які торгують органами. Я не буду повторювати всю цю маячню.
Тому вона дуже важлива для них…